[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public votre
émission de débat de chronique et de
reportage sur Public Sénat vous le savez
la promesse est dans le titre de
l'émission donné du sens à l'actualité
se mettre au service du public vous
proposer des clés de compréhension des
crises que nous traversons c'est une
visite très attendu le président
américain Joe Biden se rend en Israël
demain peut-il jouer un rôle de
médiateur l'offensive terrestre des
soldats de Tsahal est-elle inéluctable
comment les diplomates peuvent-ils
empêcher une extension du conflit on
répond à toutes ces questions avec nos
invités experts dans une minute et puis
pour notre second débat cette question
comment protéger nos écoles face aux
menaces terroristes aujourd'hui la
commission d'enquête du Sénat sur les
pressions menaces et agression visant
les enseignants recevait l'une des sœurs
de Samuel pati 3 ans après son
assassinat 4 jours après la mort de
Dominique Bernard perdre l'école ce
n'est pas perdre une bataille ni offrir
une prise de guerre à l'adversaire c'est
perdre la
guerre la sécurité la défense de la
laïcité le contenu des programmes face
aux pressions des islamistes et des
extrémistes politicorigieux dans trois
quart d'heure en détail ce qui a été
fait ou pas pour sanctuariser nos
établissements scolaires mais d'abord le
récit de cette 11e journée de guerre
avec le bilan côté français qui
salourdit Flora sauvage 21 français sont
morts et 11 sont toujours portés
disparus interpellés par la mère du
notage Franco israélienne après la
diffusion d'une vidéo de sa fille par le
Hamas Emmanuel Macron a assuré depuis
Tyrana où il était en déplacement que la
France était pleinement mobilisée pour
obtenir la libération des otages retenu
à Gaza nous sommes heure par heure au
suivi de ces discussions et je veux dire
en tout cas à la famille de mchem et à
toutes les familles que nous faisons
absolument tout ce qui est dans notre
pouvoir pour obtenir sa libération comme
celle des autres otages depuis l'attaque
surprise du Hamas qui a provoqué la mort
de 1400 personnes en Israël le bilan ne
cesse de s'alourdir à Gaza on compte
déjà 3000 morts dont des centaines
d'enfants sous blocus total 1 millions
de personnes ont fui dans le sud de la
bande de Gaza pour échapper aux bombes
israéliennes l'Union européenne va
ouvrir un point aérien humanitaire via
l'Égypte car le temps presse il ne reste
de l'eau que pour 24 heures dans
l'enclave placé en état de siège depuis
le 9 octobre par Israël nous avons
demandé à Israël qu'il mène ses
activités de défense dans le respect du
droit international qu'il ouvre des
couloirs humanitaires pour permettre
d'apporter de l'aide à Gaza et de
protéger les civils je suis sûr que ce
sera également le message du président
des
États-Unis alors que le chancelier
allemand Olaf Scholz est le premier chef
de gouvernement à se rendre dans lesétat
Hébreux depuis l'attaque du Hamas le
président américain Joe Biden se rendra
mercredi en Israël pour rencontrer le
Premier ministre israélien Benyamin
netanahou il se rendra ensuite en
Jordanie pour rencontrer le roi Abdallah
le président égyptien et le président de
l'Autorité palestinienne la communauté
internationale craint notamment une
escalade du conflit entre le hzbollah
Libanais allié du Hamas et l'armée
israélienne après des affrontements à la
frontière entre le Liban et
Israël la visite de Joe Biden le travail
le jeu des diplomates mais aussi
l'éventuelle offensive terrestre sur
Gaza on en parle tout de suite avec mes
invités le général Christophe gomard
bonsoir bienvenue un chef du
renseignement militaire Anne desine
bonsoir et bienvenue vous êtes
professeur des université juris
spécialiste des États-Unis et vous
publiez ce livre les États-Unis et la
démocratie aux éditions l'armatan pierre
razou bonsoir bonsir bienvenue à vous
aussi directeur académique de la
Fondation méditerranéenne d'études
stratégiques coordinateur de l'Atlas
stratégique de la Méditerranée et du
Moyen Orient et laticia crupa bonsoir
Léticia hitorialiste politique bienvenue
à vous ch ch on commence par l'offensive
terrestre si vous le voulez bien est-ce
qu'elle est inéluctable pour vous
Christophe Gom de mon point de vue
Israël n'a pas d'autre issue que
d'attaquer en rité contte tenu de
l'émotion qui est la l'heure contte tenu
de la la défaite et cont tenu du fait
qu'ils veulent continuue à montrer leur
puissance je crois qu'ils prennent leur
temps ça permet de de recir du
renseignement ça permet de préparer
encore mieux les troupes je pense
que quand le temps du deuil sera fini
c'est quand ils auront enterré toutes
les nombreuses victimes qui ont été
assassiné dans les kibuts sous lors de
cette rêve partie il me semble et ils
attendent sans doute également la visite
du président américain ou mais il est
probable que lors du départ de ce
dernier l'offensive débutera même si ça
sera garde un effet de surprise quand
même pour surprendre le Hamas et ce qui
permet également à une certaine partie
de la population d'évacuer le Nord comme
les Israël ont demandé de façon à éviter
effectivement ce qu'on appelle dans
notre jargon les dommages collatéraux
c'est-à-dire le fait d'éviter de tuer
des des CIV des malheureux civils qui
nont rien demander alors effectivement
on voit mal les les Israéliens
déclencher leur offensive terrestre
alors que Joe Biden est est dans leur
pays ou même dans la région on peut dire
que ça laisse un peu de répi au civil
palestinien desésine est-ce qu'il peut
c'est quoi l'objectif de cette visite de
Joe Biden apr est-ce qu'il peut demander
tiens aux Israéliens d'attendre encore
de laisser peut-être du temps à à une
négociation à autre chose alors la
stratégie américaine est claire elle a
été très bien expliquée par le
secrétaire aux Affaires étrangères
blincol qui a dit il y a quatre
objectifs répéter notre soutien total à
Israël empêcher que la région ne
s'embrase mais empêcher aussi les
retombées dans nos états et la crise
humanitaire à Gaza à gazaou c'est-à-dire
travailler là-dessus voilà vous mettez
en dernier ça sera peut-être le premier
obou que c'était le 4e que mentionnait
blinon c'est devenu le premier pour le
président Biden qui a eu une longue
conversation téléphonique avec son
homologue nataniaou le dimanche et pend
dans ce temps-l blincen et les
Israéliens parait-il dans des pièces
séparées essayer de se mettre d'accord
sur des points de mise en place de cette
aide humanitaire mais l'une des raisons
pour moi de la venue de Biden c'est
aussi de rappeler à netaniaahous qui lui
a dit à plusieurs reprises et ce qu'il a
dit dans ses discours c'est que certes
il fallait que les Israéliens
envahissent qu'ils essaient d'éliminer
le Hamas mais ça devait se faire dans le
respect de nos valeurs communes donc pas
d'assassinat massif de civil un certain
respect du droit humanitaire et je pense
que leurs conversations vont
certainement tourner autour de ce sujet
h alors que c'est c'est c'est je
rebondis tout de suite sur ce que vous
venez de dire parce que il y a depuis
plusieurs jours des informations qui qui
circulent sur l'utilisation par l'armée
israélienne de phosphore blanc de
munition au phosphore blanc je sais pas
si vous pouvez nous éclairer pierre
razou là-dessus déjà est-ce qu'on est
dans le droit international ou est-ce
que ce sont des munitions interdite
alors je suis pas juriste donc j'aurais
du mal à vous éclairer sur ce point-là
je voudrais juste si je peux rebondir
sur sur ce qu'on disait sur la venue de
Biden je crois aussi qu'il vient pour
deux raisons très claires un c'est
afficher une
dissuasion très CLA face au Hezbollah
tout en ménageant l'Iran c'est-à-dire
qu'on voit bien que depuis bah depuis le
début de la guerre le message est à la
fois sur le
thème les Iraniens n'ont pas intérêt et
ils le disent eux-mêmees d'ailleurs ils
n'ont pas intérêt à rentrer directement
dans ce conflit ce qui ne les empêche
pas forcément de d'instrumentaliser le
hzbollah et si le hbola rentrait dans un
conflit clairement leur faire comprendre
qu'avec deux portes-avion avec 2000
soldats américains mis en alerte qui
pourrait en cas de d'offensive venir à
la frontière par exemple dans les villes
ou à la frontière nord pour dire si vous
tapez sur israëlle vous tapez sur les
États-Unis avec toutes les conséquences
qui sont en sort on on est dans la
disuion AC deuxème alors oui on y
revient un peu plus tard sur le risque
d'extension du conflit si vous le voulez
bien mais je je je donc je reste quand
même sur ma question puisque c'est vous
qui l'évoquiez le phosphore blanc un mot
de vous de de précision est-ce que ce
sont des quel type de munition interdit
oui ou non parce que il y a une
polémique qui est en train d'enfler
là-dessus et ensuite on reviendra
vraiment sur la question deens en fait
les bamb phosfor si vous voulez c'est ce
que les Américains ont utilisai à dres
lorsque en 44 ou 45 ils ont 45 je crois
bombarder la ville de drez c'était avec
du phosphore donc effectivement ça ça CR
ça met des incendies à peu près partout
et c'est ça ça brûle les gens également
donc en fait je ne pense pas qu'ils
utilisent ça sincèrement euh certes ils
ont une vraie envie de vengeance euh
mais ça ils n'iront pas jusqu là c'estàd
qu'ils vont utiliser les matériels qui
sont les leurs euh éormment puissant et
massif et on voit bien à travers les
bombardements effectués ces derniers
jours d'abord ils n'utilisent pas dans
leur bombes ils ont effectué plus de
6000 bombardements en quelques jours ce
qui est en fait gigantesque déjà alors
il y a plusieurs ONG localement qui
disent que il y a des signes
d'utilisation bref voilà on sait bien
que en temps de guerre c'est compliqué
de de faire confiance à toutes les
sources comment cette offensive
terrestre pourrait se passer pierre
razou à quoi ça peut ressembler alors il
y a il y a plusieurs scénarios il y a le
scénario on va dire op enfin disons
massif euh qui voudrait voir plusieurs
percés latérales c'est-à-dire les unités
blindées mécanisées qui partent de la la
barrière de sécurité qui foncent vers la
côte vers la vers la mer pour en fait
segmenter en plusieurs tronçons la bande
de Gaza pour isoler la partie la plus au
nord là où est gaz City pour ensuite
dans la foulée alors tout ça ça se
passerait de nuit très certainement pour
lancer une offensive majeure en
encerclant Gaza c'est-à-dire depuis onit
de tous les côtés y compris depuis la
mer y compris de depuis l'air
c'est-à-dire avec des des dépôts enfin
je veux dire avec des des commandos
aéroportés ou aeromobile déposé pour
prendre le contrôle des des objectifs
stratégiques les carrefours et cetera
les grandes avenues mais ça ne ris rien
c'està dire que ensuite il faut point
par point récupérer les les quartiers
les immeubles les end le sous-sol ce qui
veut dire que la la guerre se
déroulerait sur quatre niveaux
c'està-dire au niveau souterrain les
tunnels les caves au niveau du sol
c'estàdire des avenues des rues des
rez-de-chaussées dans les bâtiments et
sur le toit des bâtiments et est-ce que
les les divinitaires de Hamas sont les
premières cibles est-ce que c'est aussi
une cible oui je pense c'est de
finalement faire disparaître ils sont
pas tous là bah on suppose qu'il y en a
certains qui on là les vrais sont à
Dubaï oui voilà disons que il y en a qui
ont probablement qui ont réussi à
s'exfiltrer les grands décideurs entre
guillemets bah qui sont au Qatar ou
ailleurs et et donc en fait reste les
opérationnels ou les opératifs sur place
et le alors ça c'est le le le scénario
optimal sinon on peut on peut penser que
quand je dis optimal enfin le plus
massif donc qui causerait probablement
beaucoup de morts et si Biden aussi est
là c'est probablement pour anticiper euh
les dégâts et les pertes pour dire à
néaniaah au cas où vous l'auriez pas
compris euh on rentre dans une guerre
médiatique c'est-à-dire que le temps du
deuil comme disait le Général gomard
étant passé on rentre dans une guerre
médiatique et si vous faites entre
guillemets n'importe quoi euh les
Iraniens les catariens les Turcs vont se
ruer là-dessus et vous allez perdre la
guerre médiatique oui c'est-à-dire que
le le poids l'émotion provoquée par le
l'attaque du Hamas les actes terroristes
les horreurs qui ont circulé aussi sur
les sur les médias sociaux ces images ce
c'est cette émotion elle sera petit à
petit submergée remplacée par l'émotion
des victimes
VO vouses c'est làdessus que il faut se
préparer à ça et c'est un des messages
que Biden veut faire passer oui
certainement et on voit bien que même en
Israël les généraux et notamment Benny
Gans qui connaî très bien les affaires
militaires sont pas forcément tous sur
la même ligne c'est-à-dire qu'ils
comprennent bien que justement pour ne
pas disons pour se donner des chances de
retarder l'impact négatif des médias il
faut peut-être prévoir et c'est la
réponse aussi à votre question une autre
tactique qui considère enfin qui
concernerait en fait à faire des raides
ponctuellesou euh ce qu'on appelle des
hit and run c'est-à-dire on rentre on
cherche des otages on essaie de les
libérer euh évidemment vivant si
possible mais s'ils sont tués dans les
compas B on les ramène en Israël et
d'éliminer évidemment des des dirigeants
opérationnels du Hamas rentrer de
l'autre côté de la frontière et
continuer comme ça d'accord sans devenir
une une une force d'occupation d'une
certaine façon ce qui retarde peut-être
l'offensive terrestre sur Gaza euh il y
a une autre question c'est le manque de
préparation des réservistes écoutez ce
qu'on disait ce matin le journaliste
Franco israélien qui est également le
directeur de la rédaction de Libération
d'v alfond on est déjà sur 300000
réservistes mais beaucoup de ces
réservistes sont des logistiques des
renseignements ne ne se sont pas
entraînés depuis des mois pourquoi parce
que soit euh Gaza n'était pas dans
l'ordre des priorités du gouvernement
israélien soit ils étaient il faisaient
partie des reféusenques qui manifestai
chaque samedi soir contre netanahou et
donc on refusait d'aller de leur dans
leur unité de de réservve cela fait au
moins un an et donc il faut préparer
tous ces gens-là il faut que les vrais
commandos arrivent il faut que la météo
soit meilleur comme tout le le système
de liaison entre l'air et et les forces
de tank infanterie et renseignement est
lié aussi à la météo elle est comment la
météo là diluvienne cela fait 2 jours ça
se calmera avec la venue de Joe Biden
alors on reparlera peut-être de
l'élément météo mais Christophe Gomar je
disais dans le quotidien Le Monde un
article passionnant sur l'impact
psychologique de l'attaque du du Hamas
sur les soldats israéliens il y a eu
près de 300 je crois 291 morts c'est le
chiffre officiel est-ce que le le
rapport de force avec le le groupe Armie
islamiste avec le Hamas c'est en partie
inversé avec cette attaque non je dis en
partie hein il y a il y a un effet
psychologique très fort en effet d'abord
jamais ils n'ont
imaginé une telle attaque c'est même
dans les scénarios les plus fout jamais
n'imaginer que 2500 combattants du Hamas
franchiraiit une une frontière jugée
infranchissable un dôme de faer jugé sûr
à presque 100 % et ça c'est la
protection aérienne protection aérienne
et une armée un dispositif militaire
suffisamment puissant pour dissuader
toute tentative donc il y a
effectivement un choc psychologique très
très fort maintenant quand on voit que
des réservistes même sont venus de
France sont venus d'autres pays pour
renforcer cette armée non il y a vraie
je dire positivité chez eux c'estàd
qu'en fait ils ont envie en effet
d'aller au combat pour éradiquer le
hamass et quand on entend les discours
d'ombre de personnalités de religions
juives qui sont là tous disent il faut
éradiquer le Hamas donc je pense qu'il y
a une vraie volonté de se battre euh sur
la préparation des ou l'impréparation
des réservistes oui ça c'est ce que ce
que disait le journaliste chef de
rédaction de Libération oui il a il a en
partie raison il a parti il a raison sur
la météo il a raison également un point
qui ne c pas c'est la préparation
vis-à-vis du hbolah c'est-à-dire qu'en
fait renforcer la
frontière de façon à éviter une
offensive au nord pendant l'attaque
effectivement sur Gaza donc
effectivement il y a il y a tout un tas
de raisons pour laquelle effectivement
ils ont sans doute retarder leur attaque
ce qui permet évidemment une bien
meilleure préparation puisque les gens
ont rejoint leurs unités ont pu à
nouveau tirer et CER et est-ce que le
fait de retarder comme cela ça ne
renforce pas aussi le camp adverse
c'est-à-dire qu'on a le temps de se
préparer euh c'est quand même aussi un
handicap pour Israël alors pour moi côté
Hamas soit c'était une tentative dire
une attaque suicide au sens où ils
savaiit qu'il y aurait pas de retour
soit il y a un deuxième temps dans leur
stratégie et euh c'est ce qu'on va voir
lorsque effectivement israël va attaquer
mais ce qui profite aujourd'hui à
l'armée israélienne c'est effectivement
le temps de faire du renseignement
j'imagine bien qu'il y a sans doute des
incursions euh E and run pour aller
chercher de l'information quit à
trouvver des sources euh humaines des
gens qui ont pas envie de voir le Hamas
ou peut-être qui ont envie de se faire
exfiltrer ça reste possible ils ont
peut-être exfiltré des Palestiniens ça
on n sait rien de façon effectivement à
obtenir du renseignement en particulier
sur les tunnels parce que la vraie
difficulté d'Israël aujourd'hui ça va
être ce combat dans les tunnels dont on
a vu dans les reportages et j'allais
dire les propagandes les vidéos de
propagande du Hamas des tunnels qui sont
qui ressemblent un peu à notre LG
maginau souvenons-nous effectivement on
voyait ces grands ces grands couloirs
éclairés dans lesquels c'est des tunnels
il y a des centaines de kilomètres ils
appent ça le métro de Gaza d'illeurs
et je pense ça vaê des combats très très
compliqués vous l'avez évoqué tout à
l'heure le andin ça a été c'est une
information que le Pentagone a a fourni
cet après-midi 2000 militaires
américains placés en état d'alerte dans
dans la
région on parlera tout à l'heure de
l'Iran de de du risque d'extension mais
si on reste sur l'hypothèse d'une
offensive TER est-ce qu'il peut y avoir
des forces spéciales américaines qui
participent à cette à cette offensive
puisque on le sait il y a des otages
binationaux et notamment des américan
israëlien pour le moment personne ne dit
cela d'accord simplement il y a un grand
déploiement al le général sera mieux que
moin il y a deux porte-avion un
sous-marin enfin il y a un déploiement
vraiment considérable et 2000 hommes
c'est beaucoup mais il faut bien voir
que ce qu'a pu faire Biden pour le
moment ca relève de sa prérogative
exécutive de même que quand il a renvoyé
des munitions et cetera tout le moment
pour le moment tout va bien il a pas
besoin de se rappelle au Congrès voilà
sauf que le Congrès dysfonctionnel vous
savez que les républicains sont
incapables d'élire un speaker oui donc
aucunjet de Budet pour voter de l'aide
alors il y a ensuite la stratégie est-ce
que Biden essaie de faire un package
Israël plus Ukraine dans le même paquet
si j'ose dire avec peut-être un petit
peu de budget pour eux parce que le 17
novembre ils n'ont plus d'argent donc
ils mettre la clé sous le paillasson et
l'administration s'arrête là il c'est
l'administration américaine c'est le
voilà exactement et donc là nous n'en
sommes même pas là mais nous n'en sommes
même pas à dire est-ce que Biden va
réussir à faire des coalitions parce que
Israël est soutenu par les deux grands
partis il y a eu des des résolutions qui
ont été signé qui ont été votés mais
dans les deux parties alors l'aile
droite les magas les fameux magas et Jim
Jordan disent c'est fini l'aide c'est
l'Amérique d'abord et à gauche pareil
pour l'Ukraine
oui oui enfin oui surtout pour l'Ukraine
mais un peu pour Israël et l'aile gauche
du parti
démocrate trouve que Biden est trop du
côté d'Israël et qu'il faudrait rappeler
l'historique le fait qu'Israël a une
partie de responsabilité dans ce qui se
passe et qu'il faudrait plutôt appeler à
un cesser le feu donc il va devoir
naviguer de façon très très compliquée
si un jour les républicains Élise un
speaker ou bien s'il y a speaker c'est
le le le c'est le alors c'est le
président des républicains qui est typso
factcto le président de la chambre mais
en l'état actuel des choses aucun projet
ne peut venir au vote si le speaker n'a
pas accepté donc
on est dans cette situation pour le
moment Biden fait semblant d'envoyer de
l'argent des trouses parce qu'il peut ça
relève et pour le deuxième porte-avion
il y a pas besoin de d'avoir le vote du
du Congrès non parce que c'est le
déplacé donc ça ça relève du ministre de
la défense du chef d'État Mar des armées
bon voilà donc pour le moment tout va
bien mais nous sommes à une semaine 2
semaines d'un moment où il faudra
l'intervention du Congrès et honnêtement
vu ce qui se passe à la Chambre des
représentants à part si les républicains
parce qu'il y en a quelquesuns qu'on
appelle les problem solvers ceux qui
veulent régler les problèmes se rendre
compte que ils sont dans l'impasse et
ils acceptent de traiter avec les
démocrates et l'ensemble les modérés
plus les démocrate ÉIS speaker modéré
avec des réformes de façon à ce qu'il ne
puisse pas être renversé de façon à ce
que tout un tas de chos Biden sera dans
l'impasse donc c'est compliqué alors
pour je reste sur ce ce thème de de
l'intervention militaire terrestre même
si on a compris qu'elle aurait elle
irait au-delà de d'une seule
intervention terrestre on va demander à
Quentin cal m de nous rejoindre pour
jeter un coup d'œil dans le dans le
rétroviseur on va remonter presque 10
ans en arrière 2014 pour se souvenir
bonsoir Quentin précédente opération
israélienne dans dans Gaza c'était
l'opération bordure protectrice voilà en
2014 effectivement il s'agit alors déjà
de la trème guerre à Gaza en moins de 6
ans les faits sont toujours les mêmes
entre de 2008 et et 2014 le Hamas aux
commande de la bande de Gaza depuis les
législatives de janvier 2006 lance à
chaque fois des roquettes sur Israël qui
répond par la force Gaza devient
véritablement Thomas le point d'accroche
du conflit israélo-palestinien dans ces
années-là mais en 2014 des exactions
sordides viennent encore tendre un peu
plus la situation le 12 juin trois
adolescents israéliens sont enlevés en
sixjordanie retrouvés morts le le 30
juin en représaille un adolescent
palestinien est enlevé et assassiné le 2
juillet par un groupe extrémiste
israélien le les 7 et 8 juillet des tirs
de roquettes revendiqués par le Hamas
font alors quatre victimes civiles
israéliennes les roquettes du Hamas
visent Jérusalem et Tel Aviv poussant
les populations à se réfugier dans des
abris et donc Israël l'armée israélienne
va faire une incursion dans la bande de
Gaza voilà la première étape pour
l'armée israélienne en 2014 ce sont les
bombardements des sites stratégiques ce
qui en fait rappell on comprend ce qui
se joue aujourd'hui puis les tanks se
positionnent autour de la bande de Gaza
là encore on est en train de voir la
même chose se reproduire 9 ans plus tard
sur des images fournies par sal on voit
des militaires viser d'abord les tunnels
qui relient la bande de Gaza à
l'extérieur de l'enclave à proximité des
Kiboots qui bordent Gaza nous sommes le
19 juillet 2014 dans une autre vidéo que
je voulais vous MONT montré les soldats
israéliens et menant des opérations dans
Gaza sont pris dans des échanges de tir
et ils trouvent dans des caches dans ces
tunnels une arme du Hamas qu'ils vont
sortir ce sont clairement ces tunnels
qui sont l'objectif précis desall à
l'époque et dans une note publiée 3 ans
plus tard on apprend de la part du
ministère de la Défense qu'au total 32
tunnels ont été détruits pendant bordure
protectrice donc 14 conduisaient vers le
territoire israélien et pouvait servir
de voies secrètes d'accès pour une
opération terroriste par exemple contre
les communautés frontalières il y aurait
aujourd'hui des dizaines voire des
centaines de kilomètres de galerie dans
Gaza contrôlé par le Hamas ils seront
une cible essentielle on le comprend
Thomas et un labyrinthe qui va
énormément compliquer aussi laassut
israélien sur Gaza et quel a été le
bilan de cette opération en 2014 45
jours de combat meurtrier entre le 8
juillet et le 26 août 2014 avec un bilan
lourd pour les populations civiles 2000
victimes 12000 blessé Palestiniens
Israël a vu la mort de 70 personnes dont
64 soldats dans cette opération 64
soldats et d'ailleurs Thomas vous le
disez tout à l'heure mais depuis hier le
bilan de l'armée israélienne est déjà de
291 morts pour ce qui se passe cette
année suite aux attaques du 7 octobre un
choc pour les militaire l'armée
israélienne ces jours-ci se se pose donc
de nombreuses questions sur l'Assou à
mener sur gazar et on comprend avec vos
échanges en plateau tant le Hamas semble
y avoir appris des événements du passé y
compris des événements de 2014 la
dernière incurson de tsal dans l'enclave
Thomas merci beaucoup Quentin alors il y
a beaucoup de questions né de de votre
chronique on par reparlera des tunnels
dans dans un instant général Gomar
est-ce qu'on peut parler d'une forme de
Guéra urbaine est-ce que c'est à ça que
les soldats israéliens vont devoir faire
face ah sans aucun doute dire que dans
un premier temps comme çaétait très bien
expliqué tout à l'heure effectivement
ils vont conquérir un maximum de terrain
et ensuite les fantassins vont débarquer
et vont fouiller les maisons chacune des
maisons et sans doute essayer d'avoir
accès au au tunnel euh et que V que va
faire le Hamas le Hamas évidemment
profitant de ces tunnels et certain
nombre de cach préparés à l'avance va en
profiter pour détruire le maximum de
soldats israéliens voire de chars voire
de véhicules blindés euh parce que
justement ils profiteront quand on
attaque quand on est assaillant on se
met en difficulté en fait on se met en
danger par rapport à quelqu'un qui
défend qui connaît bien son terrain ce
qui va être le cas du Hamas donc oui ça
être de la guerrière urbaine et
d'ailleurs le mot du chef état-major des
armées israéliennes LV à ses soldats dit
concrètement qu'ils vont bien qu'il vont
souffrir que ça va être dur mais qu'il
faut rester fort et que tal gagnera à la
fin mais on voit bien qu'ils savent déjà
que l'affrontement avec le Hamas ne va
pas être simple du tout puisque l' Hamas
va rester en partie mélangé avec la
population qu'Israël cherchera à éviter
de tuer ou de blesser cette population
donc oui ça va être très compliqué pour
sal en effet d'autant qu'ils arrivent
sur un terrain qui aurait été préparé
par le Hamas oui pierazou ces tunnels
ils ont évidemment été construit ou
d'autres ont été construits on peut
imaginer quand même que les même si les
services de renseignement israélien ont
en partie failli
euh ça a été voilà une démonstration
mondiale le le 7 octobre dernier mais il
y a des agents qui sont infiltrés est-ce
qu'ils ont un plan de ces tunnels d'près
vous désolé de poser une question aussi
basique et aussi précise c'est une vraie
question euh le plus probable c'est
qu'ils aient une vision partiale ouais
de ce métro de Gaza euh mais imaginez le
métro à Paris c'est comme si vous aviez
le plan de tro quatre lignes il vous il
vous en manque quand même beaucoup donc
donc en fait ils veulent avoir l'idée la
plus claire je crois aussi ce qu'il faut
pas oublier c'est les otages israéliens
bien sûr et la logique si on peut dire
cynique ou
opérationnelle c'est de répartir les
otages israéliens partout y compris dans
les tunnels c'est-à-dire dans les
tunnels dans les
bâtiments dans des caves et cetera parce
que dans les tunnels la problématique
des des des soldats israéliens
c'est pour détruire un tunnel par
exemple on peut bah l'étouffer le
l'effondrer mettre des gaz l'inonder
enfin il y a des tas de de procéder mais
s'ils font ça comment peuvent-ils être
certains qu'il y aura pas également des
des otages à l'intérieur donc il faut
qu'il résou qu' résolvent eux-mêmes
finalement ce ce dilemme et qu'ils
essayent de limiter les dégâts en se
disant ma compréhension c'est plutôt
progressons petit à petit c'est-à-dire
nettoyons entre guillemets enfin ou
contrôlons ou détruisons des portions de
tunnel uniquement qu'on est à peu près
certain que les otages ne sont pas là
toujours à propos des otages je vous
propose d'écouter tout de suite le
porte-parole de la branche armée du
Hamas Israël parle depuis hier de d'unun
d'un chiffre autour de 200 otages 199
lui va plus loin des comptes un peu
sordid des macab on
[Musique]
l'écoute nous pouvons estimer que le
nombre d'otag à Gaza entre 200 et 250 ou
même
plus 200 d'entre eux sont aux mains des
brigades alkassam et d'autres factions
détiennent les
autres et et et avec une particularité
on l'a déjà dit sur ce plateau c'est
qu'il y a beaucoup de binationaux il y a
beaucoup de pays qui finalement sont
concernés ça donne une dimension
internationale aussi à à la situation
notamment les les
Américains il y a le bilan américain
c'est 30 morts et 13 disparus ou otage
on est dans dans C dans ce dans ce flou
côté américain est-ce que c'est un enjeu
dans les médias américains ou même vous
nous parliez de de de la politique de la
campagne présidentielle américaine
est-ce que le sort des otages
binationaux est un enjeu oui c'est c'est
un enjeu alors tout d'abord une chose
facile c'est instrumentalisé par les
républicains qui expliquent que Biden
est nul mais ça c'est facile ils disent
qu'il est vieux qu'il est nul bon voilà
c'est pas un scoop non c'est c'est
difficile parce que la communauté juive
est une communauté très puissante aux
États-Unis la plupart d'entre eux des
Israël il y a un gros lobby qui
s'appelle hpac qui sont derrière Biden
en lui disant il faut absolument
soutenir Israël quoi que fasse netanahou
eux se moquent de l'aide humanitaire eux
se moquent des civils mais il y a un
autre lobby plus récent qui s'appelle j
Street qui lui habituellement a des
positions très propé et État palestinien
donc un partage avec deux états et là il
y a une sorte de clivage entre les
dirigeants qui qui sont relativ très pro
Israël plus que d'habitude et d'anciens
dirigeants de ce même lobby qui explique
pourquoi ce changement d'adtitude nous
avons toujours été en faveur de la paix
et en faveur de deux états donc
l'opinion est très divisée et là encore
Biden doit naviguer doit manœuvrer entre
tout ceci en essayant de de garder une
unité alors il a nommé un envoyer
spécial au Moyen-Orient dont l'une des
tâches est de voir ce qu'il peut faire
pour les otages mais ce n'est pas ça
simple et cela fera un peu desésordres
si Biden négociait simplement pour les
attages Américains et laisser les autres
se débrouillerid évidemment un mot je je
repose un peu parfois un peu têtu mais
je vous poser la même question que j'ai
posé à une desine tout à l'heure sur une
hypothèse d'intervention des forces
spéciales américaines on sait que
certains d'entre eux notamment ceux qui
étaient
intervenus au
Pakistan pour trouver Ben Laden j'
arrive pardon sont présents dans la dans
la région est-ce que c'est est-ce qu'on
peut imaginer une action coordonnée ou
pas du tout parce qu'on est sur le sol
israélien non je n'y crois pas un
instant vous y croyez pas que que la
solution soit proposée au commandement
israélien l'état major israélien ça
reste possible mais surtout ce qui est
important c'est le renseignement acquis
par les Américains qui est largement
partagé comme le renseignement
occidental d'ailleurs je pense que le
renseignement français est en partie
échangé avec les Israéliens de façon
effectivement comme les Français ont
aussi sans doute peut-être des
otages c'est j'allais dire il y a il
doit y avoir une cellule de
renseignement commune dans tous les cas
une cellule qui partage ces information
quand vous dites renseignement c'est
sont des agents physiques c'est de la
surveillance satellite renseignement
c'est plus de l'imagerie satellitaire
c'est plus de l'interception du
rangement du renseignement cybernétique
voir pourquoi pas du renseignement
humain c'est de sources parce qu'il est
possible que un pays ou l'autre et
peut-être des sources humaines au sein
de Gaza ça reste ça reste envisageable
alors juste pourquoi le New York Times
rapporte que l'administration Biden a
dit si les ennemis d'Israël élargissent
le conflit et ouvrent des nouveaux
fronts les États-Unis pour pourront
entrer directement en guerre ça ce sont
des propos que le New York Times
rapporte pourquoi ça reste possible ça
ça reste possible c'està dire que je
pense que la présence des deux groupes
aéronavales en Méditerranée orientale
sont là pour dire si on attaque
quelqu'un attaque Israël si ce conflit
sé largi nous interviendrons en fait
pour l'instant on est dans on montre ses
muscles maintenant l'intervention de
force spécial américaines au sol en
Israël ça reste possible mais je ne
pense pas que ça soit le cas réellement
allez on va on va parler de de du risque
de d'extension du conflit dans un
instant mais je voudrais quand même
consacrer quelques minutes au aux
conséquences il y a ce terme de dommages
collatéraux enfin c'est c'est c'est une
façonilà édul cororé de dire que des des
milliers de civils palestiniens vont
vont sans doute perdre la vie dans les
prochains jours et je vous propose de
d'entendre l'ambassadeur palestinien
justement aux Nations Unies qui ce matin
lancit un appel sur ce thème on
l'écoute
n'envoyez pas le signal que la vie des
Palestiniens ne compte
pas n'osez pas dire qu'Israël n'est pas
responsable des bombes qu' lar sur leur
tête ne justifiez pas les meurtres ne
blâmez pas la
victime et je le répète ne le faites pas
ne faites pas cela ce qui se passe à
Gaza n'est pas une opération militaire
il s'agit d'une attaque en règle contre
notre peuple il s'agit de massacre de
civil innocents
pierreou je rappelle le bilan de
l'opération 2014 que nous donnait
Quentin calm tout à l'heure 2000 morts
12000 blessés Palestiniens on se dirige
même si beaucoup de civils ont fuit vers
le sud bon on voit bien les les les
précautions qui sont aussi lié voilà aux
pressions diplomatiques on on l'a
compris de de néania mais enfin c'est
inéluctable là
aussi je voudrais je suis historien
aussi donc revenir un peu sur un point
depuis le début des affrontements entre
on va dire commando israélien et
Palestiniens donc ça remonte aux années
1950 hein donc c'est c'est pas hier euh
Israël dans sa posture dissuasive a
toujours montré dans les combats qu'au
résultat du bilan les pertes disons soit
arabe soit palestinienne était de 5 à 6
fois supérieure à celle des pertes
israéliennes pourquoi
pour clairement établir une dissuasion
très claire c'est vous attaquez Israël
vous allez en payer le
prix là finalement si on regarde pour le
moment les pertes les Israéliens se
disent notre posture dissuasive a été
atteinte et quelque part comme le disait
très bien le général gomard tout à
l'heure il faut rétablir une une posture
de dissuasion et quelque part montrer à
l'adversaire quel qu'il soit parce que
le conflit peut s'étendre y compris en
sjordanie on parle du front nord et de
Gaza mais ça peut être à Jérusalem en
Jord ça veut dire tu es siamment des
civils ça c'est ce que vous laissez
entendre non mais parce que c'est ce que
j'entends je dis entre les lignes en
quelque sorte non ça veut dire plutôt
euh mener les opérations militaires en
étant conscient qu'il y a un risque de
perte collatéral comme disait le Général
et que oui et puis on n pas du de la
stratégie du Hamas de placer souvent des
civils aux endroits où si le hamass
utilise des boucliers humains bah
quelque part il vont en payer le prix
allez on on ouvre le le chapitre plus
directement diplomatique même si on l'a
évoqué déjà dans ce débat donc cette
visite de Joe Biden demain rencontre
avec le Premier ministre israélien
netaniaahou il va aussi en Jordanie il
va rencontrer le roi le président
égyptien et le responsable de l'Autorité
palestinienne Mahmoud Abbas Laeticia je
me tourne vers vous pourquoi Joe Biden
s'implique est-ce qu'il s'implique de
façon personnelle d'une certaine façon
oui sur cette visite en Israël oui c'est
lui personnellement qui l'a décidé alors
on a noté que c'est vrai que c'est rare
pour la Maison Blanche d'improviser des
déplacements présidentiels d'autant plus
quand le pays est en guerre mais en
février Joe Biden est déjà allé en
Ukraine l'Ukraine était en guerre il
s'est il est allé à Kiev il s rendu à
Kiev cette fois-ci Thomas vous avez
raison c'est lui qui a décidé d'aller en
Israël alors certaines mauvaises langues
disent que c'est pour montrer peut-être
c'est sa dernière chance de montrer
qu'il a la stature présidentielle et
qu'il n'est pas trop vieux pour se
représenter mais surtout il ne se
déplace pas en terre inconnu alors on
connaît aussi ces relations on va dire
tumultueuses avec le Premier ministre
israélien qu'est-ce qu'on peut dire de
ce dialogue est-ce qui sera possible
écoutez c'est vrai que dans la mémoire
diplomatique et politique on a en tête
la visite quand il était vice-président
de Joe Biden en 2010 et d'un Benjamin
netanahou alors encore Premier ministre
déjà Premier ministre qui l'humilie ça
c'est le terme qui est resté de cette
visite pourquoi parce qu'il annonce plus
de 1000 logements en plus à Jérusalem
d'accord desexcension des colonies à
l'agenda de la visite mais surtout ces
deux hommes-là Thomas se connaissent
depuis 40 ans ce sont les pires ennemis
ou les meilleurs ennemis pourquoi parce
qu'ils se connaissent très bien qu'il se
parlent et vous avez raison Madame ils
se sont parlés directement déjà
plusieurs fois et toute la visite de Joe
Biden a été préparée finalement blinken
lui il est allé he sur le terrain il na
servi qu'au répétition Joe Biden va
venir tout a déjà été décidé en amont et
c'est pour cette raison que les médias
israéliens ont laissé fuiter là la durée
de la visite elle va durer 5h demain ça
va être Express alors bien sûr que c'est
pour des raisons de sécurité mais aussi
pourquoi parce que ce qui compte demain
c'est l'image c'est le symbole c'est
cette visite de la première puissance
occidentale en Israël je vous rappelle
que c'est nthano qui a demandé à Biden
de venir donc cette image cette photo
nous l'aurons peut-être pour la
postérité de Biden en tout cas
l'histoire retiendra qu'un président
américain s'est déplacé en Israël quand
Israël était en guerre alors vous nous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure an desine le
le effectivement l'un des enjeux de la
la campagne mais c'était le cas avant ce
cette relance du conflit Isra évidemment
avec l'Ukraine l'une des critiques c'est
c'est pas un chef de guerre il peut il
peut pas porter ce ce costume de chef de
guerre parce qu'il est trop vieux je
voudrais d'abord vous entendre sur les
relations entre Joe Biden et Benjamin
netaniaahou est-ce que c'est aussi
exérable qu'on le dit ou est-ce que ct
aussi exérable qu'on le dit alors disons
récemment elles ne sont pas bonnes mais
elles sont anciennes donc cela cela
donne une certaine
fluidité depuis que netaniaahou bah se
maintient au pouvoir de façon peu
démocratique et surtout depuis qu'il a
essayé de changer complètement le régime
en particulier en s'attaquant à la Cour
suprême euh Biden qui a comme message la
défense de la démocratie non seulement
aux États-Unis mais ailleurs sans dépris
à l'évolution d'Israël et il faut aussi
comprendre que c'est à cause cause de de
cette guerre intérieure en Israël des
réservistes qui refusaient de
s'entraîner ou même de se présenter que
Israël était affaibli et on peut penser
que c'est une des raisons pour
lesquelles le Habas a frappé maintenant
quand le pays d'abord était concentré
ailleurs et non pas sur la bande de Gaza
était concentré sur ses réformes et donc
était moins préparé que d'habitude ça
n'explique pas le défaut de de
renseignement terrible j'espère qu'il y
aura une commité une commission
d'enquête et que l'on comprendra h donc
voilà il y a un petit peu tout cela je
pense que Biden est venu parce qu'il
pense que c'est une bonne idée
effectivement il était allé à Kiev mais
je pense qu'il ne vient pas gratuitement
on sait pas exactement ce qu'ils se sont
dit il y a eu un contte-rendu de leur
conversation mais peut-être il a
extorquer un certain nombre de choses à
netanahou de toute façon il lui a promis
aussi he on parle d'une promesse qui
concernerait l'Iran et notamment la
force nucléaire en Iran oui alors moi je
n'y crois pas trop Biden a vraiment tapé
très fort il a expliquer dans ces
discours et il faut savoir que ces
discours sont bons parce que même les
républicains ont trouvé que les discours
étaient bons sur Israël donc ça c'est
quand même étonnant et il a dit tous
ceux qui auraient envie d'intervenir
tous ceux qui auraient envie de vous
mêler état ou non étatou don n'y allez
pas là vous aurez la dissuasion
américaine de là à intervenir je n'y
crois pas trop ce serait vraiment ouvrir
la porte ce serait mais l'Iran a ses
propres problèmes l'Iran va peut-être
décider de se tenir à carreau et d'agir
de façon
indirecte je vous donne la parole tout
de suite mais je vrais écouter cette
réaction du roi de Jordanie le roi
Abdallah 2 de Jordanie donc qui va
rencontrer Joe Biden également dans dans
les prochains jour qui parle du risque
d'extension du conflit avec des mots
très fort on
l'écoute toute la région est au bord du
goufre ce nouveau cycle de mort et de
destruction nous y pousse la menace
d'une extens de cette guerre est réelle
le coup qu'elle entraînera pour nous
tous est trop lourd à porter tous nos
efforts sont nécessaires pour nous
assurer que nous n'en arriverons pas
là pierreou votre avis sur ce sur ce ris
est-ce qu'il est surestimé est-ce qu'il
est réel
alors je pense qu'il est surestimé au
niveau des États mais qu'il reste réel
au niveau des des
groupementsb lesob on pourra en discuter
par rapport au au roi Abdallah la
Jordanie est extrêmement fragile et
clairement si Biden vient également en
Jordanie après être passé en Israël je
crois que le message qui fait passer par
rapport à une des questions qu'on dis
dont on discutait tout à l'heure c'est
le message c'est je reste le patron et
je reste le patron des relations
internationales et de la géopolitique
dans la région alors même que tous les
monarques et tous les tous les
dirigeants disons du Moyen-Orient se
tournent vers Pékin et vers la Chine que
les Chinois se disent on est en train de
faire carton plein dans la région Biden
tel le violon pardon tel le vieux lion
réagit vient sur place et dit euh je ne
suis pas on est toujours là et il faut
compter avec nousou ou euh d'ailleurs ce
sera un des enjeux des prochains mois on
va avoir de multiples débats pour pour
l'analyser qui prendra la main sur parce
que va y avoir des négociations sans
doute il y avir un processus de paix qui
sera relancer pas tout de suite hein on
est bien conscient mais qui prendra la
main de ce de ces négociations ça va
être passionnant c'est clair pour
rappeler à tout le monde que bien sûr il
y a l'axe de négociation Iran Qatar
Turquie ouais qui a qui a sa ligne entre
guillemets mais qui a aussi l'axe Égypte
Jordanie et États-Unis qui reste très
fort et qui n'entend pas lâcher le
morceau et que quel que soit le résultat
des négoci enfin s'il y a des
négociations à un moment donné avec les
Palestiniens ou avec les acteurs
régionaux bien évidemment les les
États-Unis entendent bien faire partie
et la France dans tout ça est petit tout
petit euh moyen Union européenne
peut-être parce que la France bon vous
préférez pas répondre Christophe Gomar
peut-être il nous reste quoi 2 minutes
sur la présence des pores-avion c'est
c'est clairement un message de
dissuision d'abord en direction de
l'Iran est-ce qu'on peut l'analyser
comme ça quand as vu américain oui mais
également vis-à-vis des Chinois
vis-à-vis des Russes c'est c'est la
présence militaire américaine et sa
puissance américaine il fa imaginez ce
que c'est qu'un porte-avion américain
fait le double de taille par rapport au
porte-avion français ouais euh c'est il
y a une centaine d'avions à bord euh ils
ont l'escor dans l'escorte ils ont des
des frégates lance-missile avec des
tomao quis ont des sous-marins euh qui
sont sous l'eau donc oui c'est on montte
la puissance militaire américaine de
fait absente depuis Obama finalement
depuis qu'Obama avait refusé de frapper
la Syrie et donc on a vu les Russes
arriver en Syrie et là c'est un espèce
de retour américain dans la région euh
fort puissant alors bien sûr et je je
rejoins tout à fait cette Ann de dire
ben attendez les États-Unis nous sommes
là nous n'abandonneons pas et donc
effectivement il rassure la Jordanie il
rassure aussi sans doute un peu l'Égypte
même si tous ces gens-là parlent avec
les Russes ou les Chinois d'abord parce
qu'ils on besoin d'argent ils ont besoin
de finances ils ont besoin de blé ils
ont besoin de tas de choses mais ce qui
est certain c'est que la puissance
américaine est présente un dernier mot
de conclusion désine c'est un changement
de pied contraint et forcé voà ils ont
voulu quitter le Moyen-Orient de façon à
utiliser leurs ressources pour le pivot
vers l'Asie pour contrer la Chine et
cetera et là de même qu'ils étaient ils
ont été contraint de revenir en Europe à
cause de la guerre contre l'Ukraine ils
sont contraints de revenir au
Moyen-Orient parce que il faut qu'ils
rappelle leur leadership dans cette
région aussi h merci beaucoup merci à
tous d'avoir participé à ce débat
indésig je rappelle le le titre de votre
livre les États-Unis et la démocratie
euh ouvrage publié aux éditions
l'armatan à très bientôt sur sur Public
Sénat